good morning Hank it's Tuesday here's a
joke that David Foster Wallace made
famous in a commencement address these
two young fish are swimming along and an
older fish swims by and says morning
boys how's the water and the two young
fish just kind of look at each other and
then keep swimming and then after a
while one says to the other what the
hell is water to ruin a perfectly good
joke by explaining it that conceit here
is that most of us do not know what we
are swimming in and cannot contextualize
our reality with the clarity or
sophistication of the wise older fish I
was 23 when I first heard this joke and
at the time I believe that adulthood was
a process through which one became the
wise older fish and so I spent a lot of
time listening to people who purported
to be that wise older fish people who
could tell me the real reality of the
world in which I found myself some of
these people were aggressively religious
some were aggressively atheistic some
were conservative some were liberal but
what they had in common was a certainty
that I found almost desperately
attractive they all told me that once I
really opened my eyes I would see for
myself that this is water
Jesus is water or antitheism is water
rigid social hierarchies are water or
radical egalitarianism is water low-fat
diets are water or low carb diets are
and all of it was compelling to me
because I so wanted to be the wise fish
in fact if you look at old vlogbrothers
videos or even more recent ones probably
you can see me trying to assume that
role I doubt if I know what I'm doing or
make pronouncements about internet life
as if I have any idea where social media
is taking us and I expound upon my many
certainties when I find my actual life
to be defined mostly by uncertainty I've
often thought that if I just pretended
to be the wise older fish I would
eventually become it but while I do
think that you can fake your way through
most of adult life I don't think you can
fake your way to enlightenment and the
truth is especially when it comes to the
weirdnesses of 21st century life I have
no idea what we are swimming in I don't
know if the social internet is good or
bad I don't know if outrage eventually
leads to better human lives and I
definitely don't know like when to
follow back or how to get that just
right makeup look for the first day of
school but here's the thing
I don't think anybody else knows either
these days one of the few things I feel
certain about is that I don't trust
people who are extremely certain about
things I'm 40 now and one of the
benefits of middle age for me is that
rather than feeling compelled by those
claiming to be the wise older fish I'm
suspicious of them now that's not to say
that enlightenment or capital a
awareness are impossible I just think
they're you know pretty uncommon I think
most of us will continue to struggle on
one level or another to apprehend the
colorless odorless transparent stuff
that we're swimming in which is okay you
can keep swimming anyway and you can
keep asking what the hell water is
sometimes you will ask that question in
desperation and fear seeking reassurance
that this water won't harm you
reassurance you can never really find
because the water will harm you
sometimes you'll ask the question in awe
or wonder sometimes in boom use mint or
frustration and sometimes in joy how can
this water be so beautiful so euphoric
so heartbreaking so terrifying I mean
what the hell is this
you will keep asking the question and
you will stay the young fish but maybe
asking the question is its own kind of
answer Hank I'll see you on Friday